K-a-z-a-b-e-l-o
but in Sesotho if there's an L followed by
a vowel it’s pronounced like a d
so it's "Kazabedo"
is her name, "Kazabedo"
come on babes, we've got something for ya
see you're too nice
yeah there ya go
squeeze it right in
there you go, good girl
I know, not so bad huh?
the big difference
that we made was really
pushing harder to get her rehydrated aggressively
and putting
the interosseous line in was
one of the bigger interventions
she just
needs a feeding tube down now as well because
she not going to be able to
and ultimately I prefer to feed through the stomach if we can
because there's also immunity involved in doing that
it's just she's took to sick to anything so this will
hopefully pump her back up a little bit
and then we'll put the feeding tube down to help.
let's do this huh
I know, I know, it's no fun, I know
she wasn't crying at all before
yeah
we're perking her up a bit
it's all right, it's down.
I just really don't want to
have to put tape on her nose but I think we're gunna have to
I would say from the time she got to clinic
her care
rivals what
we would have been able to do at
many you know
good hospitals in the United States
I wish we would have seen her sooner
I understand why we didn't
so they're about a 4 hour walk from here.
she's severely malnourished
and suffering from a
a treatable infectious disease
that wasn't treated in a
timely fashion.
That's prednisone to help
decrease the inflammation, you got it.
She's no where near
out of the woods at all
you know she's an orphaned baby
She's an orphan baby girl
and her economic prospects are limited, her
educational prospects are limited
you know I don't know if grandmother lives to be
old enough to see that child through childhood
that would be surprising to me.
So you know you have to start thinking
who is else is going
to take care of her. is she going to end up
as the youngest of three siblings, is she going to end up
in a child headed household,
you know is she then because of her lack
of educational and economic opportunities going to be
herself at risk for if she doesn't have
HIV now, she is certainly at high-risk getting
it through
sexual activity as she gets older and
either turns to that is a source of income
or is forced into that because of the
violence against women in the mountains
or uses it
as a source of solace in a very bleak
life.
"Oh! you peed! Yay! Woohoo!"
Because she is somebody who is fighting so hard
against the odds,
because the deck is stacked so against her
I think she deserves more of our fight
than someone for whom the deck is stacked
less against.
"yeah, we're making progress,
making progress"
you know when I buy my nieces a new DVD, or
try to help them you know
go to the best school they can
so they can go to a nice college, no one asks
me why I'm doing to me ask you one
that for them, I don't have to justify kindness to
children who are entitled and blessed, so I don't know
that I should have to justify it for children
whose lives have been just absolutely miserable.
You know, she had physicians and nurses paying attention
to her, she had the appropriate medications
she had good IV access
the diagnostics were somewhat limited, I mean we couldn't
check labs on her
I have no idea what her lab test would look like
and so that part, that
was sub-optimal.
but other than that I would say,
I would rate her care
here as good. as very good.
"I am giving her some plumpy nuts
to see if she will eat a little bit for us"
you know I was lucky enough to be trained
at an excellent institution with some of the best
mentors and teachers that one can come across
and you know to be able to use that to help
a little girl living in the middle of nowhere
who otherwise would be forgotten about,
it seems like the right thing to do to me.
We take it one clinic at a time.
one baby at a time.